hey guys it's Justine and the Cyber
truck is finally
here now so much has changed in my
thought process with Tesla Elon and the
Cyber truck ever since it was first
officially announced in 2019 so I feel
like we have so much to talk about at
this point in 2019 I didn't even own a
Tesla and I had zero plans on getting
one until the Cyber Tru that all changed
once I got behind the wheel of my now
beloved Tesla Model S plaid which has
been such an incredible car these last 2
years I am 100% obsessed and I guess
well I officially get the Tesla hype now
I also just got done reading the waler
Isaacson book on Elon Musk mostly
because like I've been so outraged by
some of the things that he's done
especially with Twitter or X whatever
you want to call it at this point I mean
I know it's X but it still is Twitter in
my heart so I truly just wanted to kind
of understand more about his thought
process and learn all the things that I
didn't know about his various companies
it does a really great job of not only
covering his life but the history of
Tesla SpaceX the boring company the
hyperloop the neural link and all of the
drama in purchasing Twitter and it is
such a chaotic Wild Ride speaking of
chaotic wild ride back to the Cyber
truck and how it even came to be and for
that we're going to have to go back to
over 10 years ago long before Elon ever
even thought about buying Twitter in
2012 Elon tweets about a Tesla super
truck for the first time then in 2013 we
get another tweet referencing a pickup
truck with sports car handling and Mega
torque then weeks later at Tes live in
2013 Elon is asked when we would see a
Tesla truck and while he was super eager
to talk about the project he gave no
details about when we might actually see
it then in January 2014 Elon is
interviewed on CNN Money And he says
yeah we'd like to produce an electric
pickup truck something like uh 4 to 5
years fast forward all the way to 2019
Elon puts out a mysterious teaser image
of a vehicle with like a cyberpunk
aesthetic something that legit is
straight out of Blade Runner and then
only only 3 months later Elon unveiled
the cybertruck concept at the Tesla
Design Studio in Los Angeles on November
21st 2019 now the events if you had
watched it or read any articles about it
it did have a few hiccups but after only
5 days Elon revealed that the Cyber
truck had received 250,000 pre-orders
and those numbers don't lie I'm I'm one
of them now in 2020 the Cyber truck won
the concept car of the year and then a
year later a new prototype was spotted
patrolling the streets of Los Angeles
which brings us to 2023
it is officially here production on the
Cyber truck began over the summer and in
November Tesla held the official
delivery event bringing the first dozen
actual trucks to customers now this is
super exciting now when we watched the
launch Elon obviously gave us a bunch of
updates about the truck it also still
feels weird calling it a truck because
it is so different than any other truck
or any other vehicle that I've ever seen
like just calling it a truck like it's
in a category of its own I mean just
just look at it like it looks rid
ridiculous like it definitely looks like
something like it feels like it's right
out of a video game look at that no
paint no chips Ultra hard stainless
steel shatter resistant we love to see
it look at that look at you towing and
everything so here's the interior I do
like these customizable little LED
running lights I mean even the inside
just looks futuristic with this massive
windshield I forget what the actual spec
was but I know they're saying that this
is like one of the largest pieces of
glass to ever be put in a car the one
thing that I will say is I've gotten so
used to the Yol design on my Tesla so I
do like that this isn't like a fully
circular design but I wouldn't have been
mad if this was actually just the Yol
again the thing that I do like is the
horn is an actual horn let me even just
tell you how many times I had to hit the
horn on my plaid and like by the time I
find that little button I would have
already been in an accident definitely
glad that it's a real horn thank you
thank you I also am not a fan of the
haptic buttons so this has actual
buttons that when you press for for the
turn signals it's not haptic it's an
actual physical button so you'll be able
to actually feel that you're pressing it
one of the things that I do wish this
had is a digital rear view mirror
because it is really hard to see out of
the rear viiew mirror for the most part
even now when I'm in my Tesla I don't
necessarily use my rear view mirror as
much as I would in a traditional car
because you do have all of the cameras
around the side but it would kind of be
cool if it was digital because it is so
hard to see out of the Cyber truck there
is a very small window and if you have
your cargo space closed you can't
actually see out of the window now that
three different models that you can
choose from in the Cyber Tru first up we
have the rear wheeel drive for
$6,990 this is going to be available in
2025 this will give you 250 M range and
6.5 seconds to go 0 to 60 now the
all-wheel drive will be delivering in
2024 and this has a 340 M range 0 to 60
in 4.1 seconds 112 mph top speed 600
horsepower and of course we have the
11,000 lb towing capacity and this one
is starting at 79,000
$990 and then that brings us to the
cyberbeast which is a starting price of
$999,990 with also delivery in 2024 and
this will be getting you a 320 M range 0
to 60 in 2.6 seconds 130 mph top speed
845 horsepower and also can tow 11,000
lb now towing capacity with electric
vehicles is kind of tricky because yeah
you might be able to tow 11,000 lb but
all of that added weight is going to
crush your battery so you're not going
to be towing anything very far now for
me I'm mostly concerned with range so my
initial thought process was okay I'm
going to ditch the Beast even though I
don't think it was actually called that
at the time factor in that I'd like to
have a little extra range even though
now with those final specs it's only
estimating a 20 M difference which
really isn't that much more range but
you will be saving $330,000 the car will
be a little bit slower you won't have as
much horsepower but I think I'm going to
be fine so going in here I just kind of
want to look at some of the other things
Here's the final specs revealed and
there it is the Cyber Beast so the
entire body of this thing is made of
stainless steel and it is like a
proprietary special stainless steel that
Tesla has made specifically for this
Tesla cybertruck so all the Cyber trucks
have the same exterior it'll be 95 in
wide by
223.000 in long and it's saying that
this is about as long as an F150 Raptor
it'll be 70 and 1/2 in tall though
models with air suspension will be able
to change this figure slightly so
there's a picture of it look at that
just chilling on some ice the other
thing that's kind of cool are these
tires it's cool but practicality we will
see and also fixability like how are we
going to be able to repair these tires
because they're like special custom like
these rims are specifically like molded
to fit this tire so that's going to be
kind of interesting to see how expensive
it is to fix things how Replacements are
going to go so as far as charging it'll
be able to charge at a Max rate of 250
50 KW and the all-wheel drive models
will be able to add 136 m in 15 minutes
the cyberbeast models will be able to
add 128 Mes in that same time frame now
this is something that I'm really
excited about cyber trucks are able to
power accessories via a number of
outlets through the trucks there are
four 120 volt Outlets there's two inside
and there's two in the bed and there's
one 240 volt Outlet in the bed of the
truck that'll be able to supply 9.6 KW
of continuous power so this can serve as
as a power accessory to your house or it
can charge my other Tesla or my rivan
which we'll talk about that soon while I
was searching for cybertruck things I
saw this new Cyber Vault this is a
portable wall charger priced at $800 in
China and this thing looks so freaking
cool like I want to swap out my Tesla
charger for this one because it looks so
sick now obviously the creation of the
cybertruck has been quite a challenge
and even Elon admitted to to it saying
that we dug our own grave with
cybertruck and this is where they were
offering all of the new delivery dates
now clearly this is something that is
futuristic it is different so really I
do kind of feel like a lot of these
first customers like a lot of us are
going to be sort of like beta testers I
mean the good news is because Tesla has
been around for so long and I feel like
they've worked through most of the
issues that they have with the interiors
and the interface of the actual digital
displays and things like that like I
feel like we're going to be good but
this is completely different this is all
new so it's going to definitely
interesting to see how this kind of all
pans out as more people get their hands
on them so since 2019 obviously some
things have changed so I was kind of
checking out these little comparisons
that they have here of what they had
projected and then what we're actually
getting so for example here like the
cyberbeast which is the most expensive
version they said we were going to get
500 Miles originally which is pretty
significant like if that was the case
you better 100% believe that I would
have definitely went back and ordered
the cyberbeast version but it is now
only 320 Mi but there is an extended
battery that you can get which you can
just put inside of the trunk and that
will get you 440 Mi the 0 to 60 time is
actually faster so you'll get 2.6
seconds as opposed to 2.9 Max towing
capacity they said originally 14,000 but
it looks like that's only 11,000 only I
mean I'm I'm not going to be towing
anything I don't think I mean who knows
I I never know obviously the price
difference is is quite significant
originally this was going to be 6,990
and now obviously it is a little bit
more
9,990 so yeah there's a first look at
the Cyber truck I cannot wait to get
behind the wheel and test this out for
real like it's going to be so much fun I
mean I love my Tesla already so
definitely stoked to see how this drives
how it handles like this is the car that
I would have imagined as a child this is
what I thought that all cars would look
like and I think that's sort of the
appeal of this is because it is weird it
is different and it's unlike anything
that you'll see on the road right now I
don't even know like I I look at it and
I'm kind of speechless like I I don't
know it's just it just feels like the
future and I'm excited to check it out
so that's it I'm going to go and refresh
my pre-order and hope for the
[Music]
best